hello today we're talking about the real
life get out of jail free card
for scammers bet you didn't know that
exists but it does
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 10
million dollar studio i'm your host
coffee zilla the internet detective as
usual we're talking about the bad boys
you know how it is
guys uh and again yes we're talking
about the get out of jail free card
okay how is it that somebody can say
how to make 200 to 2k per day
working less than 90 minutes a day with
a 15-year proven trading system
if you don't want to think that's a
get-rich-quick scheme ditch your 9 to 5
in college plans
no previous skills knowledge or heavy
investment required
classic get rich quick fantasy that so
many of us
naively fall victim to it's almost by
definition like if you look up get rich
quick scheme in the dictionary
pretty sure this ad is it
right so uh can this guy get in trouble
for this well
there's a there's a strategy they all
use it's a it's a thing that you might
not have noticed it's the very bottom of
the page
just it's kind of hard to see see oh you
might miss it because it's
gray text on black background i can't
even
i can't even read that obviously let's
try to zoom in and figure out what this
is all about
disclaimer the information above are my
personal results
your results may vary and depend on a
variety of factor not limited to your
background
wait didn't you say that no no previous
skills
knowledge or heavy investment required
but now you're saying that it depends on
my background wait what
experience it depends on my experience
whoa
no previous skills knowledge or heavy
investment required how can they do that
guys it's the disclaimer
the disclaimer saves you from everything
right doesn't it
that's what i've been told how members
are making 34k
passively using ai automation on the
first day pretty sure we already talked
about this but i want to show it anyways
because yes at the bottom
hey guys they're not typical results may
vary
oh see i thought that when you said 34k
per day i thought that was true though
basically here's how this works they
promise crazy things in the headline
and then in the tiny little fine detail
it's all like yeah none of this is
actually
true none of it's actually going on
which you might think like oh yeah
isn't that what like medicine does right
they're like the most common side effect
is nausea
patients also reported trouble sleeping
and vivid unusual or strange dreams
and that's true that they do include
disclaimers but they're not disclaimers
that contradict
the main point of the thing like if it's
a pill it's like
yeah this is supposed to solve like your
headache but it may cause like hair loss
right
what they're doing here is different
they're making a promise
and then in the disclaimer they're
saying the promise isn't true like that
was this
they say hey you don't need any
knowledge and then in the disclaimer
it's like actually your experience is
gonna change
what happens this one too free training
how you can profit from the best
investment of
the decade and then in the first thing
of this tiny text
please note that we are not a financial
advisor and this is not financial advice
really
i thought that you were going to advise
me on the best investment
of the decade so yeah that's how these
guys escape uh you know notice
see it always works it never goes south
guys it literally cannot go
up right oh one 29 year old trader
is quietly making 1 million dollars in
2020 guys it
cannot listen he's gonna make a
disclaimer at the bottom and it
literally
nothing can go wrong see by raging bull
staff
you know reputable agency uh and then at
the bottom of course
they say oh we're not an investment
advisor it's educational information not
investment advice see it never goes
wrong because they disclaimed it right
so everything's fine right like when we
go to their page everything should be
right where it
is wait a second on december 7th 2020
the federal
trade commission filed federal trade
commission first raging bull uh oh
everybody's in trouble wait but they
just claimed it they just claimed it in
tiny text at the bottom
wait what surely they've made a mistake
someone tell the federal trade
commission that they've made a terrible
terrible mistake don't they know
that raging bull has a get out of jail
free card
let me just ask you what what do you
think makes you guys different i mean
there's just so
many services out there right
gentlemen this is democracy
manifest